today i'm gonna help my little sister  stephanie out she recently wrote on  twitter i need your help send me a video  of you friends family singing lean on me  for a secret project any format thank  you  so stephanie  this one is for you  some  times in our lives  we all have pain  we all have so  but  if we are wise  we know that there's  always  tomorrow rolling on me  when you're not strong  and i'll be your friend  i'll help you  carry on  it won't be long  till i'm gonna need  somebody to  lean on  please  swallow your pride  if i have things  you need to  no one can fill  those of your needs  that you won't let  you  you just call on me sister when you need  a hand  we all need somebody  to lean  on  i just might have a problem  that you'd understand  we all need somebody to  lean out lean on me  when you're not  strong and i'll be your friend  i'll help you  carry on  fall  it won't be long  until i'm gonna need  somebody to  lean on  good luck with the secret project  stephanie